she couldn't get so she copied Justice
millet yeah a college student in
Pennsylvania they have them there
apparently allegedly faked her own
abduction to hide the fact that she
failed to graduate
people here do the same thing whenever
they get booked on Jesse Waters prime
time
[Laughter]
I throw him I can't come in the 23 year
old Penn State Dropout was reported
missing last Monday from the Sonic
restaurant where she worked which is
crazy calling Sonic a restaurant
but 20 hours later the police found her
safe and sound at a friend's house
initially they thought she'd been
abducted by a homeless Drifter
[Laughter]
so after the cops took her in for
questioning she began painting a picture
so absurd even Hunter Biden couldn't
sell it
she claimed to have been kidnapped from
her car on a remote Road tied up and
assaulted at gunpoint by a man in a mask
then after all that the guy just dropped
her off near her house
actually according to her description
the guy looked really creepy
foreign
police say she eventually admitted to
making the whole thing up most likely
because her parents thought she was
graduating in a few days turns out
school officials confirmed she hadn't
even been a student for almost two years
I know she's since been charged with a
multitude of crimes including creating
false alarm to Public Safety disorderly
conduct and obstruction of government
functions if convicted she could be
sentenced to another three years of
working at Sonic
thank you
Michael what's your method of hiding
your many failures
[Laughter]
in Jean Jack
do you know what I just notice hmm she's
getting charged with way more stuff than
Jesse smallot so Jesse Smith tried to
start a race war that's true and
basically plan this uh this whole thing
and expect to pull all she did was just
make an embarrassing lie I just didn't
go to school well now the Justice yeah
the law the law is going to come after
her yeah this is a this is a
heartwarming tale really really yeah
it's like there's no place like home you
know you were there the whole time it's
like Wizard of Oz she started out at
Sonic she was supposed to go to college
she blew that off spent the money and
then she had to create that outrageous
lie right now normally uh you at this
point in the story it's like wow if you
would have worked harder as as hard on
your story as in college you'd be doing
great in college no she sucks at that
too yes so so now she's back at Sonic
right yeah the whole time where she
belongs right it's beautiful it makes me
feel good Kat have you ever eaten at
Sonic yeah then what do you what do you
like about it I mean I don't know if I
like it like I guess it was there well
when you have you ever entertained the
idea of perhaps creating some kind of
elaborate hoax to get out of something I
have actually I'm not lying I have come
up with some a few yeah but this is so
dumb I mean look this story I'm just
gonna start sending it to people
whenever they ask me why I don't have
children
imagine you have a kid you get you
sacrifice all the stuff for the kid and
they turn out to be not just stupid but
so stupid that it Garners National media
attention like I I mean okay if you are
trying to hide something then maybe what
you should not do is then do something
that's going to Garner a police
investigation into you right I mean does
she really think that the parents were
gonna be like oh she goes to this school
and the school's gonna be like no she
doesn't yeah uh there were so many
things she could have done to get out of
it she should have just said she had
food poisoning yes that cops don't get
involved there that the food poisoning
is the ultimate out for everything or
stomach flu because in people like they
don't want to be near you so make you
like I don't want to get you sick I
always say explosive diarrhea yeah you
do because because most people would
never admit that kind of detail on this
was happening and it and no one's gonna
ask a follow-up question
I have explosive diarrhea and they go
like what
see they'll come in with that though is
you have to do a voice I gotta explode
you know that's why I still go with I
got Rona oh there you go two weeks off
don't even have to do a fake voice stand
on explosive diarrhea because last time
explosive was that close to my ass
things went really bad
but also if you interview claims
I claim that you've got a bathroom
problems that doesn't trigger a police
investigation it's kind of the problem
it does it what would you what would you
do if one of your kids did this did with
this what would you do you got you got
kids right how old are they no they
would never they uh no no they would
never do that they're too busy they got
too much good stuff going on oh really
yeah they wouldn't they were too busy to
fake their own kids this kid might go a
year and a half without going to college
you wouldn't know I totally would not
know it I would have absolutely no I
don't even know how they are so and one
year
one year I uh it fell to me to enroll
our youngest child in his first day of
class and I enrolled him in the LA in
the not only the wrong class the wrong
grade that's amazing that means you are
a really good dad because that's that
stuff mom should do well a division of
labor I mean
dads hey we're Progressive here
[Laughter]
yeah I identify as a mom so there
I don't even have any kids I did not
know you did your own laundry
to you Joey
um you already made a bomb joke yeah I
can't go there I don't like Joe uh have
you ever done that I honestly had I
faked a family emergency to get out of a
debate listen I was enrolled in Dalton
state college and I remember Dalton
Dalton State College in Dalton Georgia
it's nothing prestigious yeah okay and I
realized that Not only was I going to
fail but I was going to fail miserably
for having never shown up to class so I
walked to the mall and there was this
dude in a blue uniform and I signed on
the dotted line and my ass got hauled
off to Paris Island and if I'd have
known then that you could just disappear
for a day and call it into Whitfield
County Sheriffs I would have never
become a Marine a day in my life so I
can sympathize with the stupidity here I
was really stupid too until I became a
marine and uh but this is what I'll tell
you the real idiot here's her boyfriend
because apparently she told her
boyfriend that she was abducted and he
believed it too and if you believe that
bro the really fit guy that she says is
her trainer is not her trainer
you need to think about it wait you know
oh wow really yeah
yeah I mean he does visit the house when
I'm not there yeah and those pictures he
says he always offers to make the bed
yeah it's weird yeah it's not the tech
the definition on the workouts that's
not the you know all right
all right from doggy rescues to shoes
with laces we're slapping Smiles upon
your faces hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else